There's been quite a lot of recent discussion about chemical weapons.
So we thought it might be useful for you to know a bit about the chemistry so
that you can understand the discussions rather better.
So I know a little bit about some of these things in particular nerve gases,
just because some of the research I do looks at the nervous system and how we
can interact with it, uh, actually to control pain rather than kill anyone.
The use of chemical weapons really began in the first world war.
First of all, they use chlorine,
which is a sort of yellowish gas.
So you could see it coming across the battlefield.
You had trench warfare, these would go along,
no man's land down into the trenches and obviously Maman kill,
um, the, the enemy or if you've got the wind direction wrong, your own troops.
Mustard gas, which is chemical weapon,
which was used again in the Iraq Iran war in the 1980s
is although it's called the gas. It is actually liquid,
which made it particularly unpleasant because it would persist on the
battlefield for months mustard,
gas that was shot in the autumn could still be there in the spring and affect
people.
And it caused blindness for those people who were not actually
killed by it.
But the rather McCobb twists to the chemistry of mustard gas is that
it has since been used or derivatives of it have been
used in medicine and more people have been saved by derivatives of
mustard than were killed in the various uses on the battlefield.
Run up. And in particularly in the early stages of the second world war,
I guess, both sides allies and, and the Nazis,
they were both developing more sophisticated chemical warfare agents,
presumably in case the other side used it. Uh, luckily, um,
although there are lots of developments were made. Um,
luckily there was no chemical warfare whatsoever in the second world war. And,
uh, none of these, uh, items got used, but nonetheless,
the technology had been developed. Um, and so these days the,
you know, there's,
there is some knowledge out there about these more advanced systems of which
siren is one of them. Unfortunately,
terrorists can get hold of it. I've got a molecule of siren here.
Not real siren, not real, sorry. No,
that would be illegal to make that I've made it out of, uh, straws. And, uh,
these colored balls, they're quite a small molecule, uh, not many atoms.
And that's why it's volatile.
It's a gas or a very low boiling liquid here. We have a phosphorous,
this purple one, these two red ones are oxygen. The black ones are carbon.
And the thing which makes it the reactive,
um, and volatile some extent, it's this one here, this is a flooring.
And what this does is it blocks something in all animals,
uh, humans, um, called tile, Coleen Estrace.
That's what it works on.
There was great worry in the UK,
that chemical weapons,
which by the time of the second world, war were much more sophisticated,
um, might be used. So all British citizens,
even babies were given respirators or gas masks,
and I've got my father's gas smells.
I think they were presented in the cardboard box,
but my father had this rather posh leather case made for it.
And if you look inside,
it has his name is written a political Esquire,
and he's got his address, his work address,
and even his telephone number inside is the gas mask itself.
I haven't taken it out for many years and I think it might be
perished, but let's see if we can get it out.
So what is acetone Coleen Estrace,
or before I tell you what the esterase bit means,
I'll tell you a bit about Estelle Coleen.
So this is a molecule here of acid tile Coleen,
and this is a neurotransmitter.
So whenever we breathe or move our arms or do a whole range of things,
heartbeats and whatnot, um,
we use our nervous system and our brain sends a signal.
Now throughout most of it it's like an electrical cable,
but when it gets to a junction,
those signals that are transferred by neuro-transmitters and ask toll coding is
one type of neurotransmitter. So this drifts across the Sinai optic gap,
the junction and it triggers the next response.
And that response might be the arm moves or lungs breathe.
I think I may need to stand up for this. Yeah. So here are the straps,
but let's see what's left in sight. When you.
You want that response to die off,
what happens is this drifts away from its receptor and a molecule
like a Pac-Man comes along and choose this up.
And that molecule is called a acid tile, Coleen asteroid.
So that's totally natural. A very good thing. Very good thing,
because otherwise, if you move your arm, it would always be there.
You wouldn't be able to stop it and get it, come back. And again,
the breathing you'd be always breathing out, not breathing in.
There's something coming. So here we are,
this is not a completely come off.
And there is an IPS.
And the thing that you breathe through.
So you need this to go on.
And this happens in milliseconds is incredibly quick, incredibly quick.
And all that happens is that it's our style.
Cody in Australia's comes along and it takes the end off.
This is now vinegar over here,
and the other bit is Coleen.
And that gets recycled to make more as style Coleen in the receptor end.
Well, you can't see very much. It's a bit dirty.
I can just about see the camera.
I couldn't drive in this and what it would have been like walking in
the complete darkness of blackouts. I've no idea.
So that process is going on and on and on constantly in our bodies.
And what siren does is it comes along
and the molecule, which, which takes this ends group off here, let's,
let's call it this, uh, thing here.
It's this O H which is gonna happen. And that's the,
the Pac-Man molecule comes along. It swaps that for that.
And then water comes in and takes this off to make a Ctech acid
or sarin comes along and it's got a much more active
group. The flooring is really reactive, that goes,
and this attaches on, but now water,
can't take this off again.
So it's just soaked up one of these Pac-Man molecules as Tel Colina Australia's
molecules. Well, now you see it's not available
to break down the Aztec Coleen in your body.
So you've always got an on switch on your muscles.
And the thing which is deadly is, is you breathing.
Cause obviously your lungs and muscles, they move in and out.
And if they don't go one way and don't go back the other way, then, you know,
you're, you're very quickly diversification, which is why you see, uh,
in all these news reports, people with really bad breathing problems.
And it's because they can't get those muscles to work correctly
because the Coleen Estrace has been mopped up by the sarin
and the water can't hydrolyze.
Inside here will be activated carbon
charcoal,
which has a very large surface area and will absorb the molecules of the
poison gas. And I believed,
or I'm not certain that they found that coconut
Chaco was by far the best Y from coconuts. I don't know.
It just probably gave a higher surface area.
So there is an antidote. And of course,
whenever chemists have designed in the past poisonous things,
obviously they don't want to kill themselves. They're clever guys.
They invent some sort of antidote.
And the antidote is this molecule it's called prowl doxing.
And this is like super water.
So here's an oxygen here and it's connected to this nitrogen and that makes
this oxygen about hundreds of 300 times more reactive than normal
water.
And that can come along and displace the siren from the Estelle
coli in Australia. And that can go back it's business again.
Now, the other thing, which is perhaps more interesting is this,
which I bought as a school boy in the early 1960s.
As far as I remember, I paid five shillings for it,
25 UK Pentz and 60 at that
time, 60 us cents.
So not very much inside if you look,
this is a kit,
a military kit for detecting poisonous gases,
and here are the instructions how to use it here.
There's a whole lab of little different vessels.
And underneath is essentially
what is a bicycle pump,
except instead of pumping things up,
it sucks air through a hole at the top,
you put the chemical tests to here and then you punch like this and it sucks air
through. So you've got,
imagine me now wearing a gas mask and gloves because there may be chemicals.
It was that you put the thing in here, and then out of here,
you took a small paper disc.
So imagine wearing gloves and the battle raging around me.
And you put a chemical, this piece of filter paper in here,
and then you start mixing up solutions here and start pumping away and see if
you get to color.
Totally. Absolutely. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, it's, it's horrendous. The,
the lethal dose for this is around one milligram,
far smaller than the smallest sort of a sweetener pill that you might put in
your coffee. For example,
we think of Sinai sodium cyanide is being quite dangerous,
but you'd need sort of half a teaspoon full of that. So you can see these are,
these are, you know, around thousand times more deadly than,
than even Sinai item. We all know that that was a horrendous.
I think one of the problems of chemical weapons is that they are
not targeted at particular individuals in the way
that you would. If you shoot a gun at them.
You can't control them. I mean,
if you're aiming a bomb or a missile at a building, you're,
you're aiming at that building, but if you release a gas,
it's going to go over the wind, blows it.
And there's no control of who's in the way and who isn't.
Also that the members of society who are most
vulnerable, old people, young children,
are those that are likely to suffer most from chemical weapons.
Because if you know the chemical weapons about, and you're properly equipped,
such as soldiers with all their battlefield kit,
then they're relatively little danger.
You cannot easily protect yourself from exploding
bombs if they're big ones, but you can from chemical weapons.
So part of the revulsion,
I think that everyone feels about chemical weapons is that they're not targeted
to individuals and innocent bystanders can so easily
be injured or killed.
So I look at the blue one, the nitrogen,
this is a cat time that Tetra trimethyl ammonium species.
There is a huge problem now that there are aging
stockpiles and various places of chemical weapons that need to be
destroyed.